blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman
okay we have lots of news to uh start
with today some
a good some not so good and some
absolutely terrible and
we're starting there what is taking
place right now in the country of india
is almost beyond words it's a complete
humanitarian crisis as hospitals are
collapsing
under the pressure of a covid
explosion if you look at the numbers
i looked this morning and thought there
must be a mistake it looks like the
they're almost literally off the charts
and
um in fact these numbers i'm going to
show you are probably under reported
due to the poor infrastructure in much
of india
that is leading to people just dying in
the streets that's not a figure of
speech
and uh potentially not even being
counted in the number of dead from kovid
so
cases in india have surged to a pandemic
high
of 320 000 cases per day
india previously had just one peak in
mid-september they did a good job for a
long time
this new peak is more than three times
worse their previous
peak and the deaths are just as bad
spiking most recently to about
2 000 deaths per day and again
probably under reports of the real
numbers
because of the uh disconnected and rural
nature
of much of india where we we just don't
even know if these numbers are actually
the full story
now i think it's important to understand
as we
sit in the united states and look at
this that
because of india's high population india
has 1.3 almost 1.4 billion people
we have about 330 million here in the
u.s
we still have higher per capita case
rates and per capita death rates than
india
from the start of the pandemic the
difference of course
is that we never saw rates of growth
like this
if this continues for even two more
weeks we could have a dramatically
different story
and the level of hospital collapse that
india is experiencing
uh is different than what happened in
the united states we did get to full
icus
and we had a very brief period where we
were getting to the limit on ventilators
but what's happening with medical
facilities and supplies in india
is tragically almost unbelievable
they are out of icu beds in many places
they are out of
oxygen in many parts of the country i
saw one report
last night where they were reporting
from
the main sort of meter for the
hospital's oxygen supply it was just at
zero
people being left outside of hospitals
waiting for care
some are just dying in the streets the
images
are absolutely horrifying new delhi in
particular
which doesn't produce its own oxygen and
is dependent on
getting help from other areas to call it
critical shape doesn't even really
explain what it is that's going on there
a bunch of
deli hospitals tweeted essentially sos
messages over the weekend saying we need
oxygen supplies
at least 20 critically ill people died
on saturday
after oxygen supply was delayed they ran
out and it took a period of time before
they were
able to get more other countries are
trying to help
but it feels like it started too late
not to be critical of people that are
helping but
we saw this coming and we fortunately
now see joe biden sending ventilators
and ppe and test kits and more
medications many other countries are
doing the same the uk
sending ventilators many countries are
doing things but arguably too late to
help
many of the people that are dying daily
at this point in time
and yes there's also some vaccination
happening there
relatively slowly some countries are
sending more vaccines
we know from looking at the numbers here
in the u.s it takes a while for the
vaccines to make a difference you start
vaccinating
uh after two weeks that first dose
provides 85 or 80 percent protection
then you
need excuse me that's second dose
and that is a slow process before it
makes an impact vaccination won't solve
the current problem happening in
hospitals as we speak with
three people dying every two minutes
also
going in very much the wrong direction
in terms of larger countries are
to some degree not like india but the
netherlands germany and colombia
are also seeing some modest upticks
in terms of larger countries and by the
way my birth country of argentina
just a continued disaster there with a
completely incompetent leadership
lack of transparency strict but
unenforced rules vaccine cronyism
one elected official found with vaccines
in his trunk and said oh i was bringing
them to
some hospital i mean just about
everything you can imagine
it's been happening in argentina i have
friends who just flew down
vaccinated said that uh accurate mask
wearing was at about 50
um shop owners are all wearing masks
from what you read
but you walk in and the mask is down
over the throat like
you know it's it it's a complete and
total disaster and the numbers there are
also reflecting that
so globally you know it you actually
need some nuance to see what's going on
you have
some large countries like india that are
disproportionately making the global
numbers look bad
we see a resumed case decline in the
united states
we are now about three weeks
from when israel saw cases go down 90
plus percent
it looks like we are going to start
seeing very good numbers uh
last week i said we were four weeks away
now now it looks like we are three weeks
away
and then at the same time if you look at
just the global picture you say are we
really making any progress here uh we
we are but we're also losing ground in
certain places
and it's going to be listed this will go
into 2022 when you consider that many
countries
won't even really be able to start
vaccinating in a serious way
until then never mind the issue of
vaccinating children we hopefully are
getting closer to that
submitted for approval on one vaccine
for pfizer has submitted for approval on
12 to 15.
they did that at the beginning of april
we should be
days from the fda reviewing that and
hopefully we can expand that
to 12 plus so many different things
to be looking at some good some not so
good
and what's going on in india absolutely
terrible
which makes this next story particularly
difficult to parse um the european union
will be opening to vaccinated american
travelers
at some point this summer let's talk
about that next the new york times is
now reporting
uh out of brussels the center of the
euro the head of the european union
um americans uh american tourists who
have been fully vaccinated against the
coronavirus
will be able to visit the eu over the
summer
we don't know when that will start but
this is based on
the head of the eu in an interview with
the new york times
yesterday it's been more than a year
since non-essential travel from most
countries has been shut down
to europe and the eu is saying that
because
the united states is vaccinating so
quickly and because talks have been
advancing
about how can we accept vaccination
certificates as proof of immunity
the eu and the eu commission believe
that at some point during the summer now
summer is technically you know it starts
june 21st
they will be able to switch policy to
one that would restore the ability of
americans to go to
europe ursula von der lion president of
the eu
says quote the americans as far as i can
see use european medicines agencies
approved vaccines this will enable free
movement and travel to the european
union
because one thing is clear all 27 member
states will accept
unconditionally all those who are
vaccinated
with vaccines approved by the ema
um adding that the vaccines being used
here
uh moderna pfizer and jnj
are um approved uh and and considered
valid
in the european union no current
timeline
but this is sort of a top level
statement that
guidance will be coming soon and it is
looking like we will be at
70 of adults being vaccinated sometime
in the month of june it will all be
subject to
the epidemiological situation
but that it is improving in the u.s and
we are starting to see an improvement
slightly in the european union now there
are already
some uh european countries where you can
go
you can go vaccinated to estonia you can
go vaccinated to iceland you can go to
croatia
there are some other eastern european
countries where you can go
but it's relatively complicated i have
friends that have done it vaccinated
and this seems to be a much broader
discussion
the the guess is that this will include
some kind of reciprocity as well
where presuming that the numbers improve
in europe
the united states will begin to do the
same now
very important we are also anticipating
new mask guidance tomorrow from joe
biden via the cdc
regarding outdoor masking now dr fauci
has been teasing this for some time
a number of different doctors including
dr ashish
or ja and others have been saying um
you know the language they've been using
has been relatively restrained
including that uh it may not be
uh a high point of contagion outdoors
from what we believe before there was
any vaccination
dr ashish says about one out of a
thousand cases were being transmitted
outdoors
and you have to believe that that one
out of a thousand was not
someone jogging by someone else it was
people doing things outdoors
that are obviously things you shouldn't
be doing in the middle of a pandemic
before there are any vaccines but the
point is that dr ashish has been making
that psychologically if we can all say
hey you know what
outside if you're not in a big crowd of
people just normal outside
walking by others on the sidewalk biking
by someone whatever
people aren't getting sick that way and
particularly now as we approach 30
percent vaccinated
we can ease up on the outdoor masking
that is the expectation for what the
cdc will tell joe biden um and joe biden
will announce tomorrow now it's unclear
whether joe biden will say
only as it applies to vaccinated people
then you start getting into this
two-tiered thing
of saying if you're vaccinated take your
mask off outside if you're not don't
i think that there are some potential
social issues
with doing that but needless to say i
think that there will be a big
psychological benefit and possibly
more encouragement for people to get
vaccines if indeed the announcement
tomorrow
is outdoor masking is not required
other than in really specific situations
a mass of people at a concert which
there shouldn't be concerts going on
anyway
a mass of people may be entering a
stadium where
in the stadium with reduced capacity
people are spread out
but you might be funneled through metal
detectors for example
and crowded together even though it's
outside okay wear masks then
um but your typical you know bike path
whatever now to be clear i've been doing
it all along i go out on my bike i go
out running i put a mask on i
i do it because i'm a team player i
don't want to be the guy
being glared at and also there's some
degree to which you know
if if you're told to wear a mask outside
and you don't people assume
you're probably also not wearing one
inside or whatever so i've been wearing
it
but if indeed when we get that
announcement not really if it's more a
question of when
i am not going to be wearing a mask
outside once the cdc says
it is not necessary it is believed that
that will be tomorrow and my hope is
that will be another boost
to people wanting vaccines the cdc
already saying
vaccinated people can travel without
uh a significant uh notable risk
material risk
that was a great thing that made more
people say oh okay that is a that's a
that's a change i will go and get
vaccinated and hopefully an update to
mass policy tomorrow
will do the same so some signs some
signs that are good signs
some states now are down in terms of
daily deaths
to close to what you see from flu
massachusetts is an example of
recently about 10 coveted deaths a day
during the average flu season
massachusetts sees
four flu deaths a day so we are getting
down
to by virtue of vaccination a situation
where
it is going to be a flu-like situation
and that changes circumstances
dramatically
from when 200 people a day were dying
for example in massachusetts so
i believe there are good things coming
but we have to keep vaccinating as the
message
let me know your thoughts on all of this
timeline
your behavior your vaccination status
you can find me on twitter
at dpakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in
15 minutes blinkist makes sure that
you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
8 bucks a month and you get the entire
library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
the david pakman show does depend on the
support of viewers
and listeners like you you can grab a
membership at
joinpackman.com i promise it's really
easy and painless check it out
uh you might remember that back in 2017
hurricane maria
ravaged puerto rico the island of
american citizens that is southeast of
florida
we learned at the time that many
republicans
didn't know that puerto ricans are
american citizens we also
knew at the time that donald trump
didn't really seem to care very much
about it the administration was slow to
send the aid
that they did send and we know that when
donald trump went
he didn't really seem to be taking it
super seriously
remember when he showed up and tossed
paper towels into the crowd
like he was shooting hoops we're playing
that video now for our television
and online video audience but now we
have to think
it wasn't merely indifference to puerto
rico from the trump administration in
2017 and 2018 that it was actually much
worse
because of a new report from the
department of hud
housing and urban development the
inspector general
of the department of hud has issued a
report
that says that because of tension
between department of hud
and the office of management and budget
under trump
all sorts of bogus procedural hurdles
were put in place to delay
puerto rico actually getting the money
now some of you will listen to me say
this and you'll go up and you'll look at
money approved for puerto rico and you
will say hold hold hold on a second
david
the money was approved 20 billion was
approved for puerto rico
and trump announced it and talked about
it and
of course yes the money was approved but
the whole point is
approving funds doesn't disperse the
funds they are separately processed
and the office of management and budget
which would approve the distribution of
the funds
around that time started to require hud
to send grant notices for disaster
funds through an interagency review
process
for approval which never before had been
required which dramatically slowed
everything down
investigators found that omb never
required such a review
for recovery funds before and it was a
requirement created
in this particular situation former hud
secretary ben carson
would be a perfect guy to ask about all
of this he declined to be interviewed
by investigators access to hud
information
was the later denied multiple times
throughout the course of the
investigation
and the trump administration's omb also
insisted
on completely overhauling puerto rico's
property management records
suspension of its minimum wage on
federal contracts and a whole other
other bunch of prerequisites imagine
saying we're approving 20 billion for
you
but to get it you have to remove the
minimum wage
provision on federal contracts what
and some hud officials realistically
and and rightly worried that the
requirements
were number one uh
designed to make it impossible for the
money to actually be distributed
and even potentially beyond hud's
ability
to actually do two top hud officials
admitted knowing that they
were on purpose missing the deadline to
issue a notice that would unlock
billions in federal recovery funds to
puerto rico
they're not even denying it or i mean
they didn't at the time
ben carson later defended his agency's
actions by saying
trump's talking points which are oh
there were we wanted to prevent
corruption and
irregularities that's why we needed to
do this stuff then ben carson refused to
actually be interviewed by investigators
here
so now that we have a bigger picture not
only did the trump administration
allegedly block the much-needed aid from
getting to puerto rico
they also obstructed an investigation
looking into why puerto rico didn't
ultimately
get the money and there's nothing
surprising here whatsoever
last week or the week before it's hard
to keep track of all the scandals we
were talking about
another newly uncovered trump
administration scam and i said
it's not clear we will ever know the
full scope of the grift
or the scamming that this administration
did
every time we do learn about something
new like this
my reaction is of course they did that
if you look at the public disdain that
trump had
for puerto rico and you look at the
public indifference that trump exhibited
none of these revelations is remotely
surprising or hard to believe
and then of course i mean you know we we
can't really come
full circle on the implications of this
without mentioning that no matter what
comes to light
a huge portion of the 75 million people
who voted for donald trump in 2020 would
take him right back for another four
years
they would gleefully vote him back in if
he runs in 2024
and as we will talk about a little bit
later on in the program uh the vast
majority of them
still believe that joe biden did not
legitimately win
the 2020 election but there is no news
story
there is no grift or scam or revelation
that would change their minds and that's
a major
problem for the country these
revelations
show the complicit nature not complicit
the the the responsibility
of the trump administration in puerto
rico being a disaster for as long as it
was after the hurricane
uh but as much of a problem as that is
we also
have a an ongoing problem in that
the vast majority of the 75 million
people that voted for the guy would vote
for him again and we're going to talk
about that poll a little bit later today
okay let's talk about infrastructure
spending and green energy
and other things that joe biden wants to
do joe biden is actually trying to do
some interesting things when it comes to
infrastructure and climate
which includes kind of reorienting some
industries
to be more sustainable over the long
term to create jobs
in the area of green rather than dirty
energy
and the climate denying right wing is
absolutely
furious with joe biden for wanting to do
this even though he ran on it
he's just doing the things he ran on
doing and they are having a field day
over the last few days focusing on
completely bogus claims that joe biden's
climate and infrastructure plan for
america would
ban stake and beer
now what is really important to
understand about this is that lots of
the people that are saying this stuff
they stop short of saying biden has
proposed this but they sometimes
will say biden's proposals would
lead to this type of thing or what biden
actually wants is but then some of them
don't get the message that that's the
language you're supposed to use
and they straight up say this is in
biden's proposals and of course it's not
so let's go to the beginning
and figure out how this all came to be
the banning stake thing
the kernel of the for lack of a better
term the kernel of the banning stake
goes back to 2020 when donald trump said
that
in aoc's gnd in alexandria
ocasio-cortez's green new deal
cows are banned okay there was not
actually any mention of cows
in the green new deal framework back
then there was a supporting document
later released by aoc staff which said
we aren't sure
we'll be able to fully get rid of
farting cows and airplanes
now that wasn't suggesting let's try to
get rid
of cows and airplanes it was merely
stating we're never going to get rid of
cows and airplanes and therefore
we should have other ways to work within
that reality
to deal with the things that impact the
environment okay so there was never any
banning of cows that became aoc will
bankhouse
and if biden does the green new deal he
will also
ban cows now biden doesn't support the
green new deal he took some elements
from the green new deal
in and integrated it into his green
energy proposal so we're already like
three layers removed none of this is
true but this weekend
because the green new deal was
reintroduced not by joe biden
they are going nuts and the the latest
trajectory of this is that the daily
mail
ran a really weird piece connecting
biden's climate plan
to some study from michigan about meat
that has nothing to do with biden
and republicans ran with it trumpian
congresswoman lauren beaubert
tweeted joe biden's climate plan
includes cutting ninety percent of red
meat from diets by 2030
and limits us to four pounds per year
fox news ran with it saying biden's
climate requirements cut 90 percent of
red meat from diet
max four pounds per year don jr retweets
it saying i'm pretty sure i ate four
pounds of red meat yesterday
that's going to be a hard no from me but
the university of michigan study
that they are citing has nothing to do
with joe biden's plan at all
it just looks at what would happen to
emissions
if people did certain things and it
points out if people cut red meat
consumption
by 90 then emissions would go down and
the daily mail
took the hypothetical percentage
reduction and somehow linked it to joe
biden's plan
and this this is what it leads to they
just don't care
they spent the weekend talking about it
it's completely made up
and then donald trump's former economic
advisor larry kudlow
he inten unintentionally self-owned
himself he went on fox business and said
under joe biden we would have to be
drinking plant-based
beer on the 4th of july this is my new
favorite thing take a look at this
so get ready you can throw back a
plant-based beer
with your grilled brussels sprouts and
wave your american flag
call it july 4th green now
why is that funny if you know anything
about beer
you would know beer is already
plant-based
plant-based beer or as i call it beer
beer is made from water
malt hops and yeast water we know is not
an animal product malt is germinated
cereal grain that's a plant that's a
plant
hops are the flowers of the hop plant
homeless lupulus that's another plant
yeasts are eukaryotic single-celled
microorganisms classified as fungus
that's almost more of a mushroom than a
plant but it's not meat
but this stuff just gets repeated
uncritically
biden will make us drink plant-based
beer as if it's some kind of weird thing
if it were even true which of course it
isn't because it can't be true because
beer is plant-based to begin with
next thing you know we'll have
plant-based corn plant-based eggplant
might be on the menu
plant-based what's interesting about
this is that plant-based is now a
fear-inducing buzzword
even things that are plant-based by
their nature
they will stick the word plant-based on
it and it's supposed to give you a
certain
image a certain understanding it's
actually sort of like
you know sometimes you'll see uh the
gluten-free label
on like almonds and
it's just it's just an ingredient um
much the same way that the word
socialism is used to describe
the government doing anything by
right-wingers um plant-based is now
a buzzword among the right with a very
particular
connotation and they use it even to
describe things that are naturally
plant-based
now here's a strategy question do we
ignore
or challenge this stuff head-on if you
ignore
it it runs the risk of exactly what
happened this weekend
that they go crazy with biden will ban
red meat and beer
on right wing media and then it starts
to
infect the social media networks and you
start seeing legacy media reporting on
it in a way that's not as
critical of the insanity as it should be
it starts to spread uncontrolled if you
ignore it
at the same time you address it and you
know
you're spending time on it rather than
something else i actually don't know the
answer
i'd be curious to hear from you maybe
we'll even set up a poll
about this on the david pakman show
instagram page
you should be following us there find us
on instagram at davidpakmanshow
you can find me on instagram at
david.pakman and we'll be back right
after this
with dystopian new polling data from cbs
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world famous bonus
show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpacman.com that's join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21 all one word
all lowercase become a member today so
we have a new cbs news poll
asking american voters about a number of
different things which we will look at
but
one top line that just cannot be missed
is that at this point in time almost six
months out
from the november 2020 election 75
percent of trump voters
still believe donald trump's lie that he
won the election
not joe biden 75 percent of trump
voters responded that no i do not
consider joe biden the legitimate winner
of the 2020 election it's almost as bad
with republicans the idea that there's a
big difference between republicans and
trump voters 70 percent of republicans
overall
do not believe that joe biden is the
rightful winner
of the 2020 election if the numbers are
anywhere close to this uh
in reality it is another humiliating
embarrassment for the country
and for critical thinking in the united
states now what do i mean by
if the numbers are close to this in
reality it's an
it's a reasonable question to ask
whether
they actually believe it or they are
showing support for their tribe
by claiming to believe it even if they
don't to
send a message to the pollsters to the
media to democrats to
whomever it's a very stupid message to
send if that's what they're doing but
the problem
is that even if they don't actually
believe it but they just say they do on
polls
polling data like this can be used to
justify
or to feign support for all sorts of
things
either by protesters or by republican
officials so
it's a problem either way it's certainly
conceivable that there are some people
who say they don't believe joe biden won
but they kind of do and they're just
saying it for the purposes of messing
with pollsters
another issue we've covered how more
voters
than in a long time have abandoned the
republican party the percentage of
people identifying as republican has
gone down
as a result does it make it more likely
that the trumpists that stay are the
ones most likely to believe
any lie that donald trump tells and that
this is less a shift in the republican
party
believing this it's just the people that
still identify
are more of the trumpy wing which is
that why there's only five points of
difference between
republicans and trump supporters in this
particular case
that may be on the other hand thanks to
trump there's lots of previous
non-voters
who joined the republican party so maybe
we can't make such an assessment
other interesting data points from the
poll despite the controversy in
washington dc about infrastructure
spending
it's very popular 87 percent of the
country
wants to spend money on improving roads
and bridges
overall 58 of the country approves of
joe biden's
infrastructure big picture that plan
includes money for roads and bridges but
also
building out green infrastructure um
hardening and improving the electrical
grid modernizing
building electric car chargers speeding
up transitions to renewable energy many
other
great things that's popular even though
it's not clear a single republican will
vote for it in the house or senate it's
popular
overall joe biden has uh very high
approval on vaccine distribution
72 percent of the country approves of
the job biden has done on vaccines
even nearly half of republicans say
biden has done well
on vaccines on vaccine hesitancy the
numbers
they improved marginally since last
month in this same poll not by much
the number of people who are saying no
to the vaccine
is steady at 22 similar to last month
similar to other polls
the number who or maybes went down from
22 to 18
and the number of yes went up from 55 to
60.
not a massive change just outside the
margin of error those
numbers once we can vaccinate kids
would get us very close if not to herd
immunity
but it would obviously be far better if
we could get the vaccine hesitancy down
to 12
or 15 we have a much better chance uh
if vaccine hesitancy goes down to that
degree
so that's the situation much of it is
disturbing i mean
it's very disturbing of course that 75
of trump voters
now almost six months out from the
election still are saying that donald
trump won most of those people want
trump back and would vote for him again
as recent polling has shown us
you also don't get to numbers like these
without big boosts from media
and so we have to go back to fox news
and to newsmax and to oan and others
for boosting these conspiracies from day
one after the election
continuing to boost them until they
received lawsuit threats and even today
they're still hosting guests who say
this exact same stuff the network
anchors will sort of
stay silent and play more coy with it
but that's a big factor in how people
even came to believe this stuff
it's not clear how we fix it a lot of
the people who still think trump won
are the same people who won't wear a
mask indoors and they're the same people
who won't get a vaccine
because they believe it's some kind of
democratic
plot to destroy liberty even though they
also believe trump invented the vaccine
or they think the vaccine will be used
to control their minds or poison them
that's a pretty deep uh you could call
it a delusion or a misunderstanding
effect
that's deep and significant and i don't
really know how you fix that
and so maybe in that context it's not
super shocking
that you still see that level of uh the
republican party believing
trump didn't really lose joe biden
didn't really win
and what some of you are not going to
believe
is that they are sort of going at it
again
with the voter fraud stuff yeah yes
they're doing it take a listen to this
some of you aren't going to believe this
some of you are
and i don't know which is more troubling
that we would still doubt the absurdity
of the stop the steel movement
or or that any new initiative seems like
something they would plausibly do
but let's talk about what is happening
republicans
and according to rudy giuliani donald
trump is also interested in this and
following it
republicans in arizona who control the
state senate are now
ordering an audit of the state's mail-in
ballots from the november 2020 election
that 2020 election yes of course the
election was now almost a full six
months ago
and yes of course even if somehow six
months later
arizona was taken from joe biden and
given to donald trump
joe biden still wins joe biden doesn't
need the state of arizona
and yes of course the arizona results
have already undergone
multiple reviews that found no evidence
of fraud and they've been certified and
joe biden has been
sworn in so this would do nothing
but they are still pushing this and here
is rudy giuliani
appearing on former trump strategist
steve bannon's program to explain it
rudy is very interested in this audit
and rudy is claiming that donald trump
is very
interested in it as well take a look at
this i know
you're pressed for time and we are here
too i gotta ask you one thing before you
go by the way
just historic right is the president the
president has been briefed on this is he
up to speed yeah
no details president knew about this uh
starting you know this has been going on
this action of course been going on now
for about three weeks so he's been
he's been up to date and very interested
in the whole thing and and even before
the decision yesterday when i when i saw
him he was
um he was quite he he's pretty sure it
was going to happen
i mean they already lost this case two
weeks ago
so this is a last gasp effort to almost
re-argue the case
they are they they lost these about 10
days ago and
it's taken about 10 days to get
everything together and boris is
absolutely correct
they could have brought this thing any
time along the way
yeah so they waited until
the last moment and then they went into
court
and they're making many of the same
arguments they made before
so there it is another humiliating
republican
attempt to like to do what even
since again overturning arizona
which will never happen but if it did
somehow happen six months out
it would not overturn the election
results now here's a serious question
how long do you think they will be
pushing this type of thing
we know how long they'll continue
claiming the 2020 election was stolen
the answer is a long time probably
forever remember that donald trump still
hasn't accepted that he lost
the popular vote in 2016. he won that
election electorally
and he still doesn't accept the popular
vote results these people
will never accept the 2020 election
results but the real question is
how long will they contin continue
pushing stuff like this
we're going to audit the mail-in ballots
what
the real questions for me are questions
like
how has judy rudy giuliani not been
disbarred by now
why does steve bannon continue to have
rudy on to peddle
this stuff is it that good for traffic
for clicks is this entire thing an
opportunity
for someone to keep trying to make money
from monetizing
gullible people who think that this
garbage might lead to something or go
somewhere like is it is it a money grift
in that sense
it's almost remarkable how they always
act like this time we've got the mother
lode
and every single time it's a dud
remember when they put all their eggs
in the basket of that wacky witness from
michigan
melissa carone who knew nothing about
anything but she was going to blow this
thing wide open
and she just made a fool out of herself
and rudy giuliani and donald trump
here's a reminder of that by the way
at one point this was the big shot they
were taking
to overturn the results the pullback the
pull book
is completely off completely off
30 000 i'd say that poll book is off by
over a hundred thousand that poll book
why don't you look at the registered
voters on there
how many registered voters are on there
did you do you even know the answer to
that no i guess it's i'm trying to get
to the bottom
zero there's zero so my question then
is if that's how many wait what about
what about how
what about the turnout rate 120 percent
well let's uh let's let representative
johnson ask his plastic questions
so the poll book number okay there's two
things that could happen here
either the poll book number if balance
were
caught multiple multiple times there's
two options option number one
is that the poll book numbers are not
going to match they don't
the actual not by thousands and
thousands of votes that's not what we
see right now
you take a look again that one really
made an impression on me
about the poor judgment that rudy
giuliani has
about what counts as a good witness
in these situations so i don't know
i mean like maybe i'll follow up on this
arizona mail-in ballot
audit if people want me to or maybe i
won't because it's worthless trash
that's not actually going anywhere
what do you think is behind it is
someone making money from this in some
way i mean
listen there's always a lawyer making
money somewhere uh on this type of thing
when you're
making court filings and and making
motions and filing paperwork
so yeah there's probably lawyers making
money but i don't think that that would
really be the motivation
it seems that either it's being
monetized for donations in some way
somebody thinks that they're going to be
pleasing trump by doing it and maybe
that will lead to something it's not
really clear
but i'd be curious to hear what you
think is the driving force behind this
we're going to take a quick break we
will go over some of the new pseudo
scandals from the weekend and much more
glad you're with me on this monday show
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
david pakman show so we are getting
absolutely no respite
whatsoever from the profligate barrage
of
fake scandals relating to joe biden that
are emanating from right-wing media and
one thing i've learned in covering
politics is that
there are always scandals for every
president sometimes they're real
sometimes they're completely fake and
made up for political purposes no
president is perfect
but joe biden's first hundred days are
actually looking pretty good
first and foremost developing a top
global vaccination campaign
after being handed trash by the trump
administration
such that the u.s has now uh vaccinated
42 percent of the population is likely
one month from dramatic reductions in
cases and deaths probably more like
three weeks even passing covet stimulus
and getting money to people within a
couple of months of getting in with
no republican support literally zero
republican votes
for that bill reestablishing some global
relationships with countries that were
driven away by the incompetence of the
trump administration for those who care
about the stock market as many claims
to under donald trump record stock
market highs
under joe biden and it's been three
months okay
so right-wing media is coming up with
fake scandals i won't list all of the
ones we've looked at so far you know
everything from
the the relationship between joe and
jill biden is fake to
you know all these different fake
scandals there's just too many
i'm just going to focus on the ones from
this weekend alone
we already talked about the fake scandal
that joe biden would ban
meat and beer so that's one i won't go
over it again since we did that earlier
in the show
here yesterday morning is fox news
anchor
and long-time trump brown-noser maria
bartoromo
announcing that during the recent uh
world leader
climate zoom meeting biden
didn't have a u.s flag behind him
that's the scandal take a look at this
by the way in that shot i think it's
really also interesting to point out
that
president biden is the only leader
without a flag behind him
everybody has their flag when we don't
have the american flag
behind joe biden interestingly whoa that
is real can biden even recover from that
i mean that's really really serious
fox news is reporting about the absence
of a flag
during a virtual meeting as a scandal
they wouldn't report on trump's historic
global failure on kovid while it was
going on
but the absence of a flag during this
meeting is a scandal for fox news
here's another big scandal former
republican speaker of the house newt
gingrich
appeared on judge jeanine pirro's
weekend show
to tell us there are people that are
appalled janine
appalled that the biden administration
is quote flying the gay flag
at american embassies around the world
take a look at this
every idiotic thing that the buy
demonstration has done
in the first hundred days you begin to
realize
whether it's threatening everybody who
believes in the second amendment
or it's attacking everybody who believes
in right to life
or it is attacking people of traditional
values who
are appalled that this administration
would fly the gay flag
at american embassies all over the world
uh i mean you just go down item by item
and it's almost like you have a
checklist biden is disrespecting people
with traditional values which is one of
the most
impotent coded phrases i can think of
he's offending people with traditional
values because the gay
flag as he calls it is flying at
embassies
in other countries people with
traditional values
are going around paying attention to the
flags being flown at american embassies
in other countries that alone would be a
shock and if that's really what they're
concerned about
they must really not have much going on
in their lives but that's another
fake fox news scandal concocted
this weekend the next scandal is less
about biden specifically
but it's democrats bigger picture
republican congressman mike turner
was also on maria bartoromo's show
yesterday and he floated
a completely unhinged conspiracy theory
that democrats want to block the us from
making a nuclear first
strike in order to prevent generals from
defending us against the
against adversaries so that if an
adversary attacks the us
we would just get destroyed as a country
take a listen to what mike turner said
to maria bartoromo and then you've got
uh democrats
led by elizabeth warren reintroducing a
bill to block the u.s from using nuclear
weapons first what's the logic
we know there really isn't any that's
for our security um you know the bite
administration is it proposing 16
increases everywhere else but in defense
um elizabeth warren obviously wants to
you know tie the hands of our generals
um so that they cannot defend
uh against our adversaries we need to
make certain that america stayed strong
that we build a strong military that we
rise to the occasion against the
modernization of china and russia
and with that we'll be able to keep our
our allies in the united states safe
understand that what mike turner is
alleging is that there are democrats in
the senate
that are treasonous and they would allow
the u.s to just be destroyed
he's saying democrats including
elizabeth warren if the u.s were
attacked they would say
do nothing here take me take all of us
kill us take over the country
and that's crazy but also if it were
true
you would imagine that there would be
way more people saying oh these these
these are traitors and there are people
saying it but
there would be much more of that and
mike turner is completely unhinged in
his claim and by the way
uh i i thought that we didn't have
anything to defend ourselves with
remember donald trump used to tell the
stories about when i took office the
generals came to me
and they said sir we have no bullets
we have nothing so now we have things
thanks to trump
but elizabeth warren if you can imagine
that doesn't want anybody to be allowed
to use the things
and the country should just be allowed
to be destroyed and then
here are just a few little tidbits about
the steak and beer thing again earlier
in the show we spoke
about the fake story that biden wants to
ban steak and beer
like eliminate them from people's diets
by force
listen to judge jeanine talk about that
finally tonight
do you like red meat and then this
continued
so the cows must go and she went with
this for some more time here's a little
bit more
yeah i like burgers and i like my gas
powered car
and i'm sick of china having the upper
hand over us
okay so that that one has actually
infected more
serious discussions about infrastructure
and biden's climate and energy plan so
we dealt with it separately earlier in
the show and you can go back
to that segment if you want to see more
about that but in the meantime
if these are the scandals maybe joe
biden is actually doing okay
because these scandals are completely
fake and i think we can say thankfully
in the sense that
it's good when polling reflects what's
going on in the real world
joe biden's approval rating is is quite
healthy joe biden's approval on covet
vaccination is doing very well
his approval on covet relief is doing
well i i think that these are all good
signs for joe biden
speaking of good signs a very bad
situation for an alaska
state senator is that alaska airlines
has banned her from flying on alaska
airlines i'm talking here about
state senator laura reinbold
tim thompson spokesman for alaska
airlines told the anchorage daily news
over the weekend
quote we have notified senator laura
reinbold
that she is not permitted to fly with us
for her continued refusal to comply
with employee instruction regarding the
current mask
policy apparently she has not
only been refusing to wear a mask she
was even recorded arguing at juno
international airport
arguing with an alaska airlines staff
member about mask
policy and the video appears to show
airline staff telling her
the mask must be on it must cover your
mouth
it must also cover your nose like the
basics we're going back to march 2020
on masking and she had been apparently
asking about a mask
exemption with upright employees with
uptight
employees at the counter she said i was
reasonable with all alaska airlines
employees
and that she did ultimately board the
flight but she's been vocally opposed to
any covet 19 mitigation measures
she is objected to the alaska airlines
mass policy that was enacted before the
federal government enacted a mass policy
alaska airlines
had already been saying even before
biden came in you have to wear a mask
she's been calling
alaska airlines staff mask bullies
and when she was asked by
flight attendants when boarding the
flight to put the mask on
i guess she went nuts and then has
sent some kind of apology to the staff
it's all completely crazy
and this is the only airline she can
take
to go from uh between anchorage and juno
unless she starts flying private or like
could she connect somewhere in the
mainland
imagine having to fly from juneau to
like seattle
and then seattle to anchorage because
she's banned
actually even that flight i think is
only in alaska
i don't know what the hell she's going
to do quite frankly
because if you're an alaska state
senator needing to regularly get
back and forth to anchorage there aren't
really other options
other than alaska airlines and you know
i know a lot of people in the audience
have dealt with the mask
stuff when flying but you don't
necessarily expect it
from a sitting state senator even on my
flight i talked about this on my i flew
a different not alaska airlines which
as far as i know alaska airlines is
being really good on the mask stuff
not every airline is i flew a different
airline to aruba last month
fully vaccinated of course and with a
mask and everything
and there was absolutely no enforcement
of masking there were a lot of people
sitting near me who were playing sort of
koi
with the food and drink policy where
even though the airline announced
multiple times
if you are actively eating or drinking
you can take your mask off
if you are between sips or bites
put the mask on and there were a bunch
of people on the plane who were doing
the thing where
they take the mask off and they hold
their drink up
so they appear to be in the process of
actively
drinking and then they just watch a
two-hour movie on the tv screen
and just hold the drink there was no
enforcement whatsoever
at one point i saw a woman get up from
her seat and go to the bathroom
walk by flight attendants with just no
mask and then walk back to her seat
and uh i'd say half of the people near
me the mask wasn't even covering the
nose and
you know as i said i wouldn't have
traveled if i weren't vaccinated so
i wasn't bothered in that i was you know
hiding thinking i'm going to get sick
you needed a negative to everybody on
the plane needed a negative test
in order to board and i was vaccinated i
it wasn't because of that but if the
rules are right now to fly you wear the
mask i'm going to play the game if i
don't want to
wear the mask on the plane i'll just say
i'm not going to travel for the time
being
because i wanted to travel i wore the
mask whatever i think about my personal
level of risk
that i think is what's frustrating which
is you know the rules when you get on
you're told when you book the flight
you're told when you check in for the
flight
uh you're not even allowed near the gate
without a mask you're told via
announcements
and then for laura reinbold to just
continue arguing about this
you don't have to fly now you might say
well she does have to fly
she has to get back and forth from
anchorage to juno because she's a state
senator well okay
she could look at driving she could look
at chartering a plane she doesn't have
to fly on alaska airlines
nor does she have a right to fly on
alaska airlines and she is now banned
from alaska airlines no word on how she
will commute
for her work as an alaska state senator
it's not going to be that much longer
guys
if you're supposed to wear the mask just
wear the mask
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
this voicemail uh dives into
a very controversial issue of uh iq
education and financial success let's
listen to
how the caller frames it up take a
listen to this hey david um
please please please perform an analysis
and explain this anomaly
if more education correlates with higher
income level
education correlates with good or
intelligence
why did 54 of the voters earning more
than 100k
vote for trump okay explain this and i
will forever address you as sir
and i will forgive you for referring to
the university of pennsylvania as you
pen
all right take care my friend oh my god
i didn't know you weren't supposed to
say you pen
uh no list so there's a couple things
going on the link
between iq and income
is only correlated in a certain part of
the band and what i mean by
that is if you have a really low iq
to the point at which it would identify
a cognitive issue that has a very
negative impact on earning potential
but what you see is that once you get if
i
i'm trying to remember this is this is a
nasim talib has written about this
once you get just a little bit above
average iq
you don't see much of an earnings
premium
as iq goes up higher and higher uh
and so i i think that maybe the premises
here
aren't quite right um and in particular
if you set the bar at a hundred thousand
dollars
there are tons of people without college
degrees
who um earn a hundred thousand dollars
there are lots of trades
in which you can earn a hundred thousand
dollars so i i think that you know
i'm glad to address the issue of income
and voting
tendencies and you have to remember that
the one reason that people with higher
incomes
regardless of education level and
regardless of intelligence
might lean republican and this is a
historical reality
is because as someone with a higher
income they may see
uh that republicans will make them pay
less in taxes
and so i think that you know you're sort
of on to something
interesting and exploring but some of
the premises there are not quite right
on the bonus show today we will talk
about caitlyn jenner's
run for california governor running as a
republican
what will the trans community think
of a republican trans candidate what
will california republicans think
of a trans candidate a lot of
interesting dynamics there
we will also talk about joe biden
recognizing the armenian genocide
as a genocide which armenians
liked and the turkish folks did not and
there is a lot of controversy
around this we will also talk about joe
biden wanting to make
community college free but progressives
aren't satisfied with that
what more might progressives be able to
get from
joe biden on that where are we on debt
cancellation
a lot to talk about with joe biden and
education
those stories and more on today's bonus
show to get instant access to the bonus
show it's very simple you go to
joinpackman.com
and you sign up that's it and i will see
you on the bonus show
in mere moments
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman